thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slam net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even
how you guys doing I'm here in Oslo in
no way where we're going to be doing a
social experiment asking people testing
their knowledge about what they know
about the religion of Islam tell us a
bit more about this Fahad Norway is a
country with approximately 5 million
people and 200 000 Muslims Muslims have
alhamdulillah been here for quite some
time but we haven't been able to change
the narrative the perspective the
non-muslims perspective on Islam so what
we want to do now is to find out what
people actually think about Islam and
Muslims and that's excellent and that's
what we're going to be doing so stay
tuned we're actually doing a social
experiment here in Oslo I was to
understand their level of knowledge on
the religion of Islam and Muslim people
in general and um the question I wanted
to ask you is um so if I say the word
Islam what comes to your mind Allah
Allah yeah and
the hijab and yeah
Allah okay yeah interesting religion
okay yes very good people really
hijab okay good food
that's interesting yeah what do you want
to start from the religion itself the
practice of course ask you to expound a
little bit more Middle Earth nice Middle
East yeah Middle East that's uh
okay interesting yeah I know about like
Muhammad
I would say uh
mostly related to men and the women and
that's not the same rights I'm sure
you've seen some things on the news with
some kind of tensions arising between
anti-islamic elements and the Muslim
people the Muslim Community and so on
what we're trying to do here is really
engender a spirit of community cohesion
between Muslims and others by educating
people of the basics of Islam okay and
Islam really is a religion that says
that there's only one God worthy of
worship so there's one God that created
the world right do you believe in God
no
not really no you're an atheist
uh yeah or agnostic you don't know if
there's God or not I don't believe on
any God I would say I think most people
would be much happier if they uh
believed in other people and not so much
in what's
in God or Allah or anything I think I
think more I'll believe more in people
than in any religion okay so let me ask
you a question how do you think we came
to this world how do we come here
dinosaurs dinosaurs it's very very
interesting yeah I mean Scandinavia is
notorious for being one of the places in
the world that has the least amount of
religious people yes yes so the Vikings
says Middle Earth movie
yes it's the Scandinavian initiative
here where the dawa Outreach projects
which is attempting to normalize
relationships between Muslim people and
other people normalize Islam in this
country doing dawa and bringing people
to Islam strengthening the Muslim
Community is the biggest of this kind
and so you do really want to miss an
opportunity like this where you can
encourage these kinds of discussions
this kind of Outreach I don't think you
do and these are the efforts that were
slam that has put forward of course in
creating this Masjid and dollar Center
we can have an Outreach project which
will fulfill those two objectives in a
way that's never been fulfilled before
and Scandinavian history and that's why
I say click on the button below and
donate right now so the idea really is
this is that um as I say Islam is just a
religion which believes in one God
worthy of worship we believe in the same
kind of prophets that are in the Old
Testament so Moses Abraham and so Noah
all of these kind of things and Muslims
believe in that yeah it's just like Jews
for example Christians believe in that
Muslims also believe in Jesus Jesus
Christ yeah but we don't believe that he
is the god or the Son of God so these
are some of the you know things about
Islam as a religion of course Islam is a
religion which allows for people to do
their own thing and we do our own thing
so this idea because some people think
Islam for example is a religion which
oppresses or tries to convert or
forcibly convert people this is not
something which is in the religion of
all Islam you see this is something
which people have said about it which is
not actually true a lot of people when I
ask what do you think of Islam the first
thing they'll be thinking about is
someone blowing themselves up someone
like me someone like me blowing
themselves up of course but this is why
it's important to have these discussions
because frankly as you said correctly I
think it's the basics of Islam it's just
basically believing there's one God
worthy of worship you see Allah and the
five pillars of Islam I'm sure you've
heard of them and the six pillars of
Iman the Creed and so on and we believe
in the Old Testament prophets Abraham
Moses Jesus and so on so there's a lot
of continuities between Islam's religion
and those which the West is used to
think of the Christianity and Judaism so
on yeah so
um we interactions with Muslims have you
found that they have been particularly
pernicious uh evil people or has it been
a normal Direction no I think they're
very loving compared to Norwegian guys
you know they call people terrorists but
you know it's just it's just the scenes
you know they're they're playing games
on us yeah I have Muslim friends and I
talk about these things all the time
yeah exactly yeah and so I think you're
a very open-minded person and you can
tell you know from your demeanor the
fact that you wanted to speak to me you
know and so on and so what I would
suggest is that if you want more
information about Islam of course you
can read the Quran which is the
religious holy book of the Muslim people
of course yeah so that's something I
would invite you to do which is the last
book I told you I'm going to read
honestly tell her tell tell him
I told her like just a few days ago I'm
going to read the Quran really like my
father did you know Christian man but he
wanted to read the Quran to understand
people wow and that is fantastic so this
is like consider this to be a sign she
already dude bro she already read the
Quran wow really no wow wow so
she's you can't let her win you can't
let her win she's already getting all
the cultural capital yeah so I was going
to say they've started an initiative
here in Norway
um it's basically a big Center which
they they give free Quran they give you
know advice and speak to people who want
to understand more about the religion of
Islam yeah
YouTube YouTube thank you so much thank
you
very open-minded people thank you very
much my friends take care see ya and
this is an example of someone from
Norway who's very open-minded very
courteous very open uh and and this
shows you that people are not really
interested in this kind of right-wing
stuff here it's not something which is
uh it's widespread as maybe the media
actually makes it out to be and the man
was wanting to read the Quran as a sign
maybe from God that he wants to read the
Quran and here I am
giving him all the information and
telling him giving him another incentive
to read the Quran but look at them these
people in Norway imagine they want to
read the Quran but imagine there's no
one there to give it to them
but we have someone there to give it to
him now which is the biggest tower
center with the qurans and translations
and English and so on we'll give it to
these people and because it can't just
be one conversation even if this man
converts now which let's say I could get
him to convert but it doesn't mean
anything if there's not an Aftercare
program if there's not someone to speak
to them if there's not someone to to
help them and we need to help them by
clicking the link below right now
because this is the biggest outreach
program in Scandinavia
so click the link below and we'll be
able to do this project where we can do
this downward to the people in the
streets of Norway and in Sweden and in
Denmark and in all of Scandinavia today
click the link below you cannot afford
to miss out on this opportunity
brothers and sisters let me introduce
you to Norway this is a European country
where the vast majority of people have
become irreligious there are 200 000
Muslims of a population of about 5
million and most of these 200 000
Muslims have no idea how to explain
Islam to their non-muslim friends and
neighbors what that means to change
Allah sent his Messenger to call people
to Eternal success and that is why
Muslims in Norway are now establishing a
Masjid and Dao Center to enhance the
Norwegian dower but they cannot do this
alone we need to support them if you
donate to the schools you will insha
Allah reap the rewards thousands of
Muslims coming back to Islam and many of
those will become Dwight and invite to
Islam you will share in the reward for
all those shihadas and Good Deeds to
come in so click the link and donate now
and share the video for extra reward